hey guys and welcome back to the Layah
Heilpern show powered by icon plus so a
quick news announcement for you as always icon is
kicking off 2021 with the launch of d5 projects
omm finance um balanced dao icon phi and its new
governance system cps all developed to financially
support contributions to the ecosystem so always
some great news coming up icon there um i want to
say thank you to my sponsors blockfi i use
them to earn up to 8.6 interest on my usdc
i think that's insane um i don't think that
kind of resonates when i say it that's 8.6
interest especially when we're seeing negative
interest rates across europe i think we saw
0.01 from the bank of england so that's pretty
crazy and then you can also get i think it's 250
depending on how much you um deposit with them
so i've left the link everywhere should be in the
bio the comments wherever it should be um and a
final shout out to coinflip so they are doing some
incredible work across the states to push bitcoin
mass adoption they now have 1 200 bitcoin atms
so giving everyday people access to bitcoin i have
a discount code if you want you can get 10 um off
your transactions so i'll leave that somewhere
in the comments so today we have a really cool
guest um somebody who i really admire somebody
who i've become quite friendly with recently
thinks she's brilliant and i just want to learn
more about her so let's welcome bitcoin liz how
are you doing hey i'm doing good thanks for
having me on and thanks for the kind words
i've been following you as well and i've
seen your guests on the show so i feel
like super super oral that you chose to to get
me on the show it's it's great to be here yeah
it's great to have you because i feel like we've
just met this year we've both sort of just like
popped up out of nowhere um well i guess sort of
seems that way for everyone else but you know we
only just met this year and i kind of want to
know a lot more about you who is bitcoin liz
what is bitcoin there's so before we talk crypto i
want to know how would you sort of define yourself
tell us something about who you are okay yeah
define i think this is always a tricky question
but i i guess a part of uh what defines who i
am you support my my background so i'm born and
raised in sweden to estonian parents and i grew up
with two native language at home quite modest home
and yeah my parents were immigrants so they
they kind of had to build up a new life here
they were really young when they moved here
and um i guess the estonian mindset has been
with me for ever since in the beginning i've never
really could place myself in one place i'm not
either swedish or estonian it's kind of having
the boat which i think is cool uh and uh yeah
we're talking about the estonian mindset
i think we're all yeah what is that
yeah because um estonia got independent from the
ussr we started uni in 1991 and you know we built
up the country from scratch basically and everyone
in estonia would say are you know we don't don't
take anything from granted we know that we need
to work hard to become successful and to make a
living and i think that is something that has
been with me ever since beginning and really
defined who i am because sweden was a welfare
state long long before estonia got independent and
i don't think the same mindset exists in in the
young people in twitter in general today so yeah
we we grew up here in stockholm in the suburbs and
uh um i went to estonia school here in sweden and
uh it's really been a part um of everything and
another thing uh fun fact i guess show is also the
estonian way thank you i got my first uh robert
kiyosaki book which that poor dad from from my dad
when i was 11 years old and he was like read this
you need to know this you need to understand this
because then you will become rich in the future
and you know how to make passive income i didn't
even know what passive income was then and how
to protect your wealth from sharks and all that
uh of course i didn't understand everything in
the book by then but it kind of like saw a seed
in me or from early on which has been with me
for yeah ever since since then but yeah to to
just define myself i would say i'm a kind person
i i'm really curious important that i have around
me i show a lot of caring and take take care
everyone around me i'm really active i'm almost
like restless i need to have something to do all
the time i love to have many things ongoing all
the time and that's that's when i perform the best
that's when i feel the best i'm also curious every
every time i visit a new country i want
to know about the culture the history
i'm not the one who goes to like history museums
or like that i'm out in the streets exploring
i want to know uh everything about the place i'm
visiting and uh yeah learn as much as possible
about the place yeah and i think answered i think
you answered that like that the best way i've ever
heard somebody ask a description about themselves
yeah you went into detail so i think that's really
interesting we said about the estonian mindset um
i think i i've spent some time in eastern europe
and i really like that i really like there
is a mindset it's kind of like a hard work
it's quite unemotional isn't it as well given like
the history like you said um and it's kind of just
like no matter how cold it gets no matter how hard
it gets we push through you know i i quite like
that but you're based in sweden so this is insane
um because you are literally one of i know there's
probably three other countries on this planet
but you are the pop you are living in a country
that has not had a lockdown this is insane so
we need to get into this because i've so i'm
based in the uk it is horrendous here um you know
christmas was cancelled thank you boris johnson um
our what else was canceled new year's eve is
cancelled everything is cancelled gyms are
shocked it's quite unbelievable i then fled and
went to romania where it's equally as nuts there
nearly got fined for wearing a mask outside
for not wearing a mask outside sorry
um but you're living your best life off in sweden
where there's no lockdown tell us how's it been
yeah well it's hard to imagine how it would be
with a lock that have to say so i'm extremely
grateful that we have had quite a normal life
uh the worst thing here was when the gyms were
closed for two weeks i couldn't go there but other
than that yeah it's it's been very very normal but
again it's hard to know if it's the right way or
not because i in the summer for example i don't
know what happens to swedish people but but with
summer comes everyone starts partying you know
hanging out which which is like normal of course
yeah but i do also believe that that may may cause
the virus to spread more to elderly we didn't take
as much care of elderly people that i i believe
we would have uh or should have done uh but of
course again i'm super super happy for it for the
freedom and actually like that the government
puts it in our hands it's our choice like
what we do and take responsibility uh together and
not that the government takes the decision for us
so in that place way i'm really happy the
way it is because i cannot imagine how it
like tough it must be with a with a lockdown
especially like mentioning that i'm restless
i need to have something to do all the time um
so yeah it's been well relatively normal but
like what's the mentality though because like the
mentality here for example and actually globally
is very much we should you know lock down
even harder um you know we should wear masks
all the time um it's it's really intense so do
swedish people not sort of share that mentality
are people not putting pressure on your government
particularly journalists are they not putting
pressure on your government at all yeah now
now they are putting more pressure because
well it looks like we are not doing that well
comparing to neighbor countries however one
thing that i see like in general among the general
public is that we are very aware of mental health
issues and we believe that we will stop a lot of
this happening in the future so that is something
that we always lean back on that no matter what
we at least stop this we made sure that people
can hang out with each other and not put ourselves
yeah in mental health issues which is yeah it's
widely spoken about in sweden it's not a taboo
uh topic to discuss and i believe it is like that
it's having a long time not being able to
socialize it it affects you a lot and so there we
are all i think agreeing here that we are
doing the right thing but then of course
the end result it's difficult to say i would
say that now people are maybe putting more
pressure on the government and now the government
is well telling you that we're doing this together
we have a common responsibility to make the best
out of the situation do you think you're locked
down do you think sweden will will sort of fall
to the global pressure and lock down sorry if they
like did you think do you think that's
full to like the global pressure
and eventually lock down in 2021 or do you think
they would have done it by now i think they would
have done it by now and it's like too late to back
down i think it's it would be weird to do it now
uh so i i don't believe in it now we got straight
more like strict restrictions during christmas
and europe that we are not allowed to be more than
eight people in in the same room and like that but
it's just recommendations you know it's not that
you you will get fined or anything for it and so
still we have the the choice to make um and yeah i
respect that i really do i respect that i respect
the fact that you have the choice you know i i
respect the recommendation and then i respect the
freedom to do as you wish for the recommendation
um but let's let's chat about crypto i want to
know how did you get in to crypto was it through
ivan or was it after him or did you get him
in like what happened yeah so um shortly i got
in like a couple of months before i met ivan
but i didn't know that much about it so long story
short i i was um while i was studying business
administration at university and i was taking
well business administration is like really broad
program you have finance marketing organization
and all that but in my finance class uh we talked
a lot about how uh well the stock markets work and
we were touching a little bit upon that there are
uh i think like digital currencies and then i
remember a couple of guys in my class they were
bragging how they made tons of money on bitcoin
and i was like okay did that caught my attention
so i started to you know google more about it
what is this and um i don't know for me right
away i was like okay this this is how future
money would look like when i read about it
and um that's when i invested like or put
money in in bitcoin the first time but i didn't
honestly i didn't do that much research
before i i made my first investment but again
yeah so this was in november 2017 uh my first
but it wasn't a lot of money that i missed i
mean i was a student and i didn't have that
much savings or anything but i i was already
a little bit invested in stocks and this was just
a natural thing to to money as well um but so so
that then i kind of follow it a little bit but i
i was definitely not following any influencers on
youtube or anything about it just a little bit
maybe and then i met ivan in april 2018 it was
through my thesis partner i was writing my thesis
then and um she knew i when she was following
her him on on youtube and she was just like we
saw him in a co-working space because we were
working there or studying there and she went to
talk to him and i was like okay i'm gonna go say
hi to this guy i don't know who is and then we
spoke a little bit about crypto and he told that
he's involved in that and um yeah i think we asked
like okay where do you see crypto going and i
said my opinion that i believe that for mass
adoption we need uh you know facebook come up
with their own currency or something like
that which which happened as well they did
yeah yeah we can talk about that and um yeah so
i would say that i was involved before but ivan
really got me involved when i met him because yeah
he got me in on crypto conferences and i started
to see that there actually this is a real industry
and people are building so many cool projects and
uh yeah so that this was during the ico bubble
uh basically when me and i went and started
to go to crypto conferences um yeah so uh
yeah yeah it was actually yeah super cool
uh so i would definitely not be that heavily
into crypto as i am now without ivan no way
that's cute i like it so let's talk about bitcoin
for a second then so you put a little bit in back
in november 2017 not enough to sort of be sort of
living on a beach and be done with with everyone
but talk to me about bitcoin because i know you're
super bullish on bitcoin it's bitcoin liz it's not
all coinless um yeah so oh list bitcoin so tell
me what is it about bitcoin that just really
makes you think yes this is the future why bitcoin
why not a different currency so i think when i
first read about it the thing that grabbed me
really was that it's you know there's no central
authority third party involved um between there
so it's maybe one of the big most basic things
uh about it because i was at that time i was angry
with the banks because i remember i opened my
first savings accounts and at in the beginning
i earned interest on the money i i stored that
but then in sweden we got negative interest rates
and i had to pay them for for storing my money so
already there was i was unbelievable yes it's
unbelievable i was like i'm having my money
in the bank i'm paying them but they can use that
money to you know even earn even more interest
so already there i was angry with the bank so how
long were negative interest rates going on across
europe because i know that they were going on
i mentioned at the beginning of the show but
we've not really seen that in the uk and i
think the bank of england have ruled it out
but how long have you guys have negative interest
rates and what are people doing to circumvent that
so we have had it since well ever since
i got my first bank account basically one
year after so i think it's like eight years
it has to be and and people don't really
think about it as an issue anymore it's it's
normal now people i mean i i understand why
you would do it to stimulate the economy people
to spend but it's been easy look at that as
blackmail though but okay yeah like i always
see that as blackmail because it's kind of like
it's kind of like you have to spend your
money otherwise we'll spend it it's like
i think it's insane um but i want to look at 2020
because 2020 has been the most crazy year um so
what would you say some of the most interesting
and the most significant things are that have
happened in crypto this year yeah so a lot has
happened yeah and i guess we need to start with
the bitcoin harmony and that caught a lot of
i would say mainstream attention i remember
remember when it's uh in the spring i was still
working at my old job which is uh like traditional
company not sex savvy people and they were like
oh i heard about this bitcoin hobbing thing and i
was like oh how uh so of course it gave bitcoin
a lot of attention and then yeah um and it was
an important event um especially for for a
bit from price now i guess and that's priced
in there just gonna jump in do you think it's
priced in like do you think that's what we're
seeing now as a result of the halving i don't
know it's so hard to say i i honestly i think
no i don't think it's completely priced i
don't know i don't yeah it's difficult to say
i yeah i'll i'll leave with that i i don't
think it's completely uh no uh priced in but
of course you remember the excitement before the
hallway after halloween so that was definitely um
something i remember um and um then of course
the d5 summer and with all the projects
and also i mean that was really when we saw true
innovation uh because i i believe that nifa is uh
challenging traditional financial services it's
possible that there are real projects and um
and of course just the institutional money that
has uh run into bitcoin it's crazy now we are
really put on the map i mean micro strategy we
have yeah people took us and i mean people see
yeah square everything so we have like
really significant people speaking up for us
and that makes yeah we can't be ignored anymore
due to that it's really really important and
that part um yeah yeah i mean i think you know i
would definitely say that 2020 has to be actually
i would i would go as far to say as it's been the
most powerful year for the industry um for so many
different reasons um okay you can look at d5 it's
like your sort of like initial example because
that inherently just challenges the traditional
system right i think it puts people in the
financial map people can borrow money do what
they need um you know money that they obviously
previously never have access to um but you know
the halving was insane i mean that was just like
an incredible it's always an amazing marketing
opportunity for bitcoin um you know the printing
of money that we that we've seen i always found
like that just kind of was insane because i'm
always obviously trying to get more people into
crypto i'm trying to sort of like explain to them
why bitcoin is going to be surnamed is going to be
so um revolutionary um and it's so hard sometimes
to sort of explain that to them especially when we
talk about countries like venezuela which see like
hyperinflation and we don't really see that kind
of inflation in the west but then you can sort of
give them this this sort of case study of 2020 and
just sort of be like look how much money is being
printed like you know um choose something which is
a deflationary asset something which has you know
um deflationary sort of strategies built in
the harbinger stuff i just think it it's been
amazing and then you know because you and i were
chatting yesterday and we were also talking about
um how important things that people like paypal
are and microstrategy and all this stuff because
i just think that you know people like jack
dorsey people like michael saylor they don't put
millions into or billions i can't remember how
much it was at this point but they don't put
that much money in um to sort of sell at like
even 10 grand higher i don't believe it i don't
believe that they're not and there was also um
that rapper what was his name it begins with l
is it is it lock lock oh gosh i'm really not
good i'm not it's not it's not my thing that but
what was his name if anyone remembers
his name write it in the comments it was
lock or lock oh i don't know but he he put
a lot in and so many different celebrities
as well who put a lot in this year and i think
that's also just like another um incredible i
guess sort of marketing opportunity for
bitcoin um but in terms of the pandemic
how do you think that has affected bitcoin so
in general i think it has had a good effect um
because it kind of made people rethink about
how i believe at least like how the monetary
system works just with the stimulus in
the u.s uh you kind of think that okay
how does it actually work that you can just bring
endless amount of money and devalue your own
uh you know developing the currency uh i
would be frustrated if i would be in the us
and see that kind of stimulus being printed and
but again also people got the stimulus checks and
they had more money to invest so they started to
look okay what should i do with my money but even
that got me but even that got me like because
i okay so it's no secret that i ten that i'm
that i don't fall on like the left of like the
political and economic and like fiscal system
i think that's no no secret if you follow me so
like when people when the government are handing
out money and then people put it into bitcoin i'm
in like two minds about that yeah so i'm just like
i'm like that's great that you put it into bitcoin
that's cool but like don't you need the money
isn't that why the government gave it yeah
like you need it to buy like groceries and
stuff i don't know yeah yeah no i i i agree
but your friends are and your family okay so
when you talk about what you do when you talk
about bitcoin number one how into it are they
do they think you're crazy if you manage to um
convince anybody to buy any bitcoin um and how do
you describe it to them like what do you say and
you know you're sitting around the dinner table
or whatever and you're so just like oh my god
bitcoin reached new highs like what do they think
yes it's very mixed feelings i i think my older
like grandmothers and grandfathers they and they
have a difficult time to understand it but they're
kind of like okay i know you you are smart so yeah
i i trust that you're doing the right thing um but
my one of my grandma yeah my grandma she really
understands because one of the advantages of
living in estonia is that it's super digitalized i
mean you can't do anything by going to a physical
place everything is online so even my grandma she
she understands that everything is online and yeah
that's where it is and that's how the future is
going to look like so it makes it easier for them
to understand that money is going to be digital
as well and even estonia was one of the first
countries to start looking at the like own digital
currency i think they even they planned it yeah
in the beginning with vitalik even but then yeah
then eve took off and everything so it was put on
a hold uh so i think for for them it's still quite
natural but they have a hard time to understand
like okay but so what what actually gives it value
what's the value of position and and that part
um but so usually when i explain i just explained
that so we own you know the network there's no one
who can tamper with it and and it's secure it's
backed by blockchain technology all that and um
yeah so i i i don't get they don't think i'm crazy
they just think it's okay it's super cool that
she has something that she is interested in
and uh yeah and i remember when i was working
at my previous job as i mentioned which was a
traditional corporation people were actually
quite interested they were like okay she knows
something that can be used used in the future so
i i instantly got interesting to people because of
that they asked me quite a lot and i remember
even one of my closest colleagues and who i
worked with closely she she eventually invested
in bitcoin because her brother was more as well
but we talked about it like all the time and
she understand that you know people have the
the pre-assumptions that it's for criminals
and it's only criminals involved there
but when they see that okay i'm in there and
i'm actually like doing a lot of research
exactly so so then it created a lot more trust for
them as well and yeah i managed to get at least
one email uh in bitcoin yeah i think that's so
funny we said um about your grandma there because
my grandpa he lives in the north of england so i
went up to see him just before the pandemic had
kicked in just to help stock his fridge and all
that bless him um and he literally thinks i work
in something really criminal i'm not being
funny he turned around to me and said does
your father know what you do i was like what do
you mean like he he literally he can't he he he
can't even understand facebook bless him he um he
sort of thinks like so he he was looking for like
a grocery store nearby or something and you
can sort of go on groups on facebook and ask
um so my mom has said you know go on facebook and
ask and my grandpa was like oh do we call facebook
you know like yellow pages yeah so there's
kind of no yeah there's kind of no hope lesson
but you know my my mom is bitcoin crazy yeah
she's crazy like every day so she i've got her
on block five and every day she's like she's
like yeah like let's look at my portfolio and
i'm like mom i was like you need to chill like
you just need to calm down and she's like tell
me when to sell time we went to sound i'm like
no we don't smell okay we don't sell we hold
um and then my brother as well he he didn't buy
i told him to buy a 10. i told him about earlier
but we were having a serious discussion at 10
because my mom had got in at 10k um and a bit
earlier but she got in property at 10k and i
told my brother to get in and um he was just
like no i'll buy below and i'm like i don't think
it's going below you know how long it spent at 8k
how long it spent at 9k and then it did go above
10k then it went down again there was that point
when we sort of knew that nobody made the joke
anymore nobody was like we're not going to see it
everybody knew we weren't seeing below 10k again
um so he didn't buy and now he's like thinking to
buy at 26 and i'm like oh my god yeah but at least
you got i mean that's really cool together and
so it's so fun to hear that your mom is like
all in it's nice but she's too much literally
she absolutely stresses me out constantly she's
like like oh i get a message again i don't get
good morning my dear loving daughter i get 28.1 oh
i'm like mom you need to stop but you're also um
really big on ethereum so i kind of want
to understand what it is about ethereum
and why do you like it um there are a lot of
concerns sorry there are a lot of concerns
that it's um a lot of ether were pre-mined um and
that it's it's not as decentralized or whatever
or what are your thoughts in it there and why
you say bullish on it so i think you can't
really compare ethereum to bitcoin i think they
these are different uh purposes so so bitcoin is
a great store value i would say uh while ethereum
is it provides something different um i would say
now with d5 and all the rivets the derivatives
and everything that it is providing i think
that that is huge for it um and yeah i i really
don't think you can compare to bitcoin in the
same way um and um just how big the community is
and how they are building and what it enables to
for for the blockchain industry as a whole i think
that is super important and as well now especially
when we have a lot of attention on the um ripple
lawsuits actually sec has said that ethereum is
is not a security which kind of gives a you know
it it makes this room a good choice because you
know that the sccf has at least said that you know
it's it's not a security you won't have that issue
uh with the dream but other than that's i don't
know i just think you it provides a lot of value
for for the crypto community and uh yeah yeah
especially with the king of the old saying
yeah no but especially looking at the derivatives
market it's huge it's it's really really big and
yeah that's that's what comes with it yeah i think
um so the ceo of old coinbase i always say this i
have to cite him um he told me the best he sort
of break it down and the clearest way to kind
of understand and he was like bitcoin is gold
2.0 ethereum is digital amazon and i was like
oh okay i was like i can work at that i
like that that makes a lot of sense so
you know they're they're different and they're not
comparable and you know bitcoin is in a league of
its own in its own way and a theorem is in its
illegal of its own in its own way doing whatever
it does with smart contracts programmable money
and so on decentralized apps and all that stuff
um i think it's pretty cool but what are
the projects have you got your eyes on
for 2021 any other alts which you're interested
in and you want to share with us yeah so
i thought about that a lot i'm not that into alts
i mean i follow a lot of projects just to see
what is out there um recently what i
got my eyes on is is polka dots i think
the yeah what they're doing is great and they
have performed really well now recently as well
so so that is definitely something that i will
keep an eye on in 2021 as well because yeah
it's a great ecosystem and uh just just the the
interoperability they are providing um between
yeah it's important for and i think they're good
doing great and now i think they are like what
are the top top six stop seven something yeah i
think or something like that yeah definitely yeah
something like top six or something um but i have
an interesting question i really want to talk to
you about because people must come to you all the
time and ask you you know can you talk about my
projects whether it be on youtube or whether it be
on twitter or wherever it is so there are almost
so many new projects you know we said like defy
was um huge in the summer it was like summer d5 so
how do you spot a scam so what are your best ways
to work out whether something's number one a scam
and number two whether something is just a really
crappy project and you know you don't like the
fundamentals or you don't like the marketing
behind it or whatever it is you don't really sort
of believe in it so how do you sort of spot that
and then decide whether or not to talk about it
um so yeah we can start with the the scan part i
think it has become much more difficult to to spot
a scam because they're getting better and better
um but i think what you need to look like at is
what they are offering um if they are offering
like guaranteed um yeah returns on investment
it's probably not true because yeah you can't
guarantee things like that and we have seen many
projects that are guaranteeing like okay at least
this percentage of return on investment uh no it
doesn't exist in the real world so yeah if it does
seem too too good to be true it probably is and
um yeah i think also looking at the team if they
have a if they're open with the team working with
them it's also a good sign i know many projects
in crypto also they want to be anonymous and
and all that but i believe if it's for me at least
it's important to know that real people and who
they are working behind the team and the project
and then of course i mean looking i think what
makes this scam successful is of course the human
psychology because we do believe that it might be
something really good that's how bit connect
and onecoin got so big and i'm talking about
onecoin it they they their strategy was to you
know target people who had no clue about crypto
and the crazy thing is that i even had an old lady
at my previous job she had invested in one claim
yes yes what did they say no she was contacted
by like her some relative and said like okay you
will get you'll get return on investment you just
need to put this in and you know and she said like
but i don't really know what it was i just said
that i would get more money for this and i'm like
you know it's so sad to see and that it works um
and i even had one relative uh who had invested in
one coin so one coin was like really really crazy
but that would really show how naive people are
and um yeah they are really believing which is sad
which is sad um but again i think i'm hoping that
as big of a scam as one coin was and bit connect
we won't see again um because i will we have
become smarter but again um if they are really
promising like guaranteed returns it's probably
that's a big warning sign
and but other than that the
answering what projects i would work on and not i
think as long as yeah i'm looking at the use case
if i see that this maybe it's not the best product
but if it can bring more adoption it can be simple
i don't know uh merch bitcoin merch i mean somehow
people still love it i am mean to that because i
i love clothes i i like i'm not going to show
those things and i think it's also a way to
spread awareness about crypto um and yeah
i mean at least you have a product right i
think i think that's kind of like the thing which
i've kind of landed on um through this whole d5
thing is like do they have a product because
there's so much conversation and there's so
much talk and there's so much like technical
language um which really kind of like coats
an absence of anything in the middle right like
what is their product there's no product there's
no use case they don't do anything and then i'm
you know people are just buying into something
and that is something which is like become such
an issue for me um you know i have uh it doesn't
matter who i i saw a company a company came
and sort of said will you work with us um and
i was just reading through their white paper and
their website and i'm just there like this is
just a lot of language where's your product and i
didn't see the product and i sent it to some send
it to the people at all coinbase as well because
i think they're great and they read it through
and they're like leia no that's not a good one
and i was like i didn't think it was you know
there's no product um another thing i'll say as
well um in terms of sort of like a new people
getting into the space um which i obviously want
to ask you about um i totally agree with you when
it comes to anonymous um anonymous character so
like of course i'm absolutely pro anonymity pro
privacy each to their own do what you want freedom
liberation you get you get the point um but as an
individual on this side somebody who's potentially
an investor or a trade or whatever i and you guys
like asked me to sort of think okay how much do i
want to invest in a project which has an anonymous
founder simply because they can't be held
accountable for their actions so there's nothing
necessarily inherently wrong with anonymity it's
just they can't be held accountable and i think
that's what people need to consider you know
what would you say some of the main things are
people should consider before getting in so yeah
it depends on on what is important for you for for
me example as i mentioned i would like to see the
people behind it because that that is a way that
that's the thing that is important to me just
because that's the way i decide uh if i believe
it on and or not um but of course then again i
think you need to think what are the like the um
what are the things that are going to matter
in the future like you have to think about
is this going to be an important thing in
a couple of years and a couple of months
and to really see the potential in it and if you
don't understand what what their vision and what
the goal is of the project then probably it's
not a good thing to invest in because i think
it's important that you understand the product or
the service that they are they have and some can
be super complicated as you said they're not even
having a product so i think it's important that
you understand it because that makes you better
at evaluating if it's a good product or not and
there's a lot of people just writing a lot
of words as you said without having a true
meaning and it just sounds good but it's
not really clear what what they're actually
providing i wondered if you had any thoughts um
on ripple the sec you know have you been following
it at all i have been following a little bit but
honestly not not i mean that much i think i think
it will have a huge impact on on us of course but
again um i wasn't that into ripple before i didn't
think there were a great project or anything like
that i didn't have anything invested in them and
but i think this shows as well that the sec is
having an eye on us and that there might be coming
more things like this and that's also why as i you
know chat yesterday i'm hoping for an etf i think
the sec needs to um just because we have so much
institutional money it's we're not talking about
just you know us the crypto community having
their money now now it's actually billions
of institutions who have the money they have a
responsibility to make sure that it is a secure
and regulated in a good way uh market that's their
responsibility so i think they won't get away with
it and we might see more cases like this come
up of course yeah i think it's kind of strange
the whole thing is just odd in my opinion um like
it makes sense yes but i was been talking to some
people and doing some research and i think from
what i've read and what i understand i think brad
garlinghouse sort of sold i think more than half
of his xrp like over a year ago like this time
last year which is just odd in my opinion you
know like these lawsuits or whatever like they
don't come out of nowhere i just find like the
timing kind of strange um but what do we know um
what do you think um 2021 is gonna look like
then um we spoke yesterday so we were trying
a bit about stable coins cbdc's so nfts
what is that going to look like in 2021
so first of all i think more and more
people will get involved in crypto
and especially now institutions joining and
yeah we are put on the map we had yeah as we
mentioned microstrategy square fidelity blackrock
and we had even a new institution today i think
joining so it's almost last one every day maybe
i think it was massive it was the other week i
think today was something like green that it was
something yeah i'm not sure but it you know we
see this almost every day so it's not even that
significant anymore um but that's that means that
more and more people will like okay what is this
actually that these institutions are putting them
running and so i definitely think more um a larger
group of people would be part of this community
and um again i think bitcoin will uh will lead in
2021 and yeah it will reach new all-time highs for
for sure i'm i'm sure of that and nfts might come
back more and now we kind of have cooled off there
if we really can find um use case for them that
yeah i mean not even now the use case is good but
i think um it takes a little bit time to to evolve
it and put it in actually in real life as well
as we added yesterday you can actually use
it in retail and to for products to verify
the authenticity of it and then again i believe it
will be big in gaming and collectibles in asia is
like specifically people love collectibles there
it can be yeah whatever so um i believe nfts can
can come back and um yeah we we don't know what
what's coming next next there will definitely be
something completely new and it will be exciting
for sure that's all we know um but yeah i mean i
i definitely agree with you i think um nfts i
mean i i said this to you yesterday i've said
this to everybody before i always say this i'm
just a broken record at this point but i i like i
mean it wholeheartedly the whole world is
going digital like dating is digital eating
is digital working is digital everything
is digital it's just inevitable that
everything else will go digital and you know we
were talking about um like designer handbags you
know rolex watches or whatever it is of course
you know verifying them um verifying that
authenticity will be digital and you know i think
blockchain technology will be a part of that um
like we were saying whether it says an nft or not
who knows um but just finally what are your final
thoughts um to just about crypto in general to the
crypto community just speak directly to them from
the heart you know okay well i first of all i love
the crypto community i'm so happy to be part of it
and i do believe that we are early on very early
on and we will get rewarded for it in the future
uh so even though someday it might feel like am
i doing the right thing i might you know question
yourself is this a crazy industry actually
like is this all made up you know sometimes
i get at least those thoughts but i want to say
like yeah it's normal that we get those thoughts
but just bear out i mean we are this community
is growing and it's really really great there
are real projects being built and i do believe
that we will see like more worldwide adoption
and we will um yeah we will really get rewarded
for it in the future and i think when we think
about blockchain technology at this whole i think
it will be a part of many businesses it is today
as well one of the things with estonia if you can
return back to that estonia is using blockchain
in healthcare 90 of our medical data is
stored with the blockchain technology
so i think we will see a lot more solutions like
that the businesses are actually going to use it
to protect data and to verify products where they
come from in supply chain and that would also of
course mean that there will be more jobs made in
in blockchain industry will create more more jobs
and more people will enter just because they
see it as a job opportunity career opportunity
as well and in general i think we would we
will mature really quickly and it will be
just another industry that we have now and
each industry probably in tech but it will
be a natural part of many businesses because
there are really really good use cases for it and
it would be yeah stupid for businesses not
to to take advantage of that and yeah and as
uh as mentioned before i think we will
probably see more regulations as well from
scc has to um take their responsibility or their
role and make sure that it is a secured market
yeah i'm absolutely with you i think regulation
is coming um i don't know whether we'll like it
or not i don't know whether they'll start
from the beginning i imagine regulation and
the likes of cbdc's will absolutely sort of be
some kind of war with with the community and like
yeah initial sort of like ethos and i guess gold
for the community um but yeah we'll have to see
how it goes i think i can't remember what you
said but it sort of made me think of the idea
that like i feel you know investors and people
like you and i um you know we're sort of like at
the end of the day gambling not just our money
but like our careers on the on the success of
the success of bitcoin isn't it because
if bitcoin fails then like they say yeah
everything else fails but hey we believe in it um
so where can people find you so you can find me on
twitter uh liz bitcoin or bitcoin liz
and youtube as well uh same bitcoin is
and instagram if you want to that's more private
and connected to to our puppy um but yeah there is
lizette which is my full name there you go liz
thank you so much for coming on guys thank you
so much for tuning in don't forget to tune in next
thursday it'll be back to normal time so it will
be 12 est which is five gmt if you're in europe
that's six e s no et that's it too many time zones
alright guys thank you so much for tuning
in we'll see you next time bye thank you bye